this next story is so toxic in the sense that
it confirms that there's an entire [inaudible]
political movement for whom politics is just
sport and friendships and cronyism and that
nothing about actually helping people or doing
what's good for the country matters.
And I'm going to cover it because it is important,
but for different reasons than some of the
headlines are suggesting.
So Anthony Scaramucci went on CNN yesterday
and breaking news.
He says he's no longer supporting reelection
for Donald Trump.
He's still a Republican.
He likes Trump's policies, which is just hilarious,
but that someone else may be should run for
the Republican Party in 2020 and I have to
hand it to CNN.
John Berman, who was interviewing him.
Berman exposes that this is just a personal
problem between Scaramucci and Trump.
It doesn't really have anything to do with
Scaramucci.
Now finding Donald Trump's behavior deplorable,
which every normal person should.
By the way, this is sport and Scaramucci.
His relationship with Trump has soured.
Now the backstory is Scaramucci is a longtime
Trump supporter.
He was briefly White House communications
director about 10 or 11 days, and since being
removed from that role so quickly or resigning,
he maintained support for Trump over the weekend.
Scaramucci made some very light criticisms
of Donald Trump's visit to El Paso, which
was a horrifying visit.
I mean, the Scaramucci was wrong in that he
didn't criticize Trump enough quite frankly,
and Trump fired back saying, Scaramucci knows
nothing about me and all sorts of other stuff.
Income Scaramucci on CNN and starts to sort
of sound anti-Trump Anthony.
Last week when I asked you if you still supported
and the answer was yes.
This morning when I asked you if you're calling
for a change at the top of the ticket, you
said it should be considered.
So are you know
longer as of this morning itchy, she'll be,
or I'm, I'm in a neutral, I'm now an an I'm
a, I'm a Republican, so I'm not switching
parties to support a democrat.
I bought, I believe in the values and the
policies, the Republican Party, but I'm, I'm
now neutral on the president.
You're now neutral.
Yeah.
We continue to act and if he, if, no, absolutely,
you have to, you have to get into a neutral
position.
And so you are no longer an active mind.
You were no longer a Anthony.
I just, I just don't want the past this by,
so people, you are no longer an active supporter
of president Trump and his reelection bid.
Yeah, I think that's, I f
I think that's pretty obvious from over the
weekend.
I mean the guys actually dissembling a little
bit and he's sounding more and more nonsensical
and you know, we're sort of an ssis to it
and people inside of Washington.
Oh yeah, that's just president Trump.
Just let them act like that.
Right?
He's still a terrible person.
He still believes in the values of the Republican
Party.
He still believes in Donald Trump's policies,
but he's changing his tune on Trump.
But then John Berman points out and I'm glad
that he does it.
Hold on a second, Anthony.
Nothing has changed as far as Trump.
All of the reasons that you are claiming are
the reasons you no longer support Trump are
backing off of Trump have been the case forever.
Trump's language, Trump's tone, Trump's handling
all of this stuff.
The only change is that you and Trump got
into an argument over the weekend on Twitter
and here is how Anthony Scaramucci response.
I was going to say, so the one intervening
event over the weekend was you had a Twitter
exchange with the president where he criticized
you directly.
All the other stuff is stuff we've seen from
president Trump for years.
At this point from when he was before president.
So, so, so what changed exactly over the last
few days?
Hey, so yeah, so, so you and Alison have often
asked me that and people say, well, okay,
where's the red line?
Where you, you, you, you break from your support
from somebody cause you remember loyalty is
symmetrical.
It's not asymmetric.
And so, so what I said to you last week was
this is really polarizing.
This is very, very divisive.
As a supporter of his, I would caution that
we now go in this direction.
You brought up stochastic terrorism in our
last interview and I suggested, okay, I can
understand how this charge rhetoric coming
from the bully pulpit of the presidency could
lead to some unintended tragic consequences.
So
that's the reality.
Long story short, he's no longer a supporter
of Donald Trump's reelection.
Big Win.
Wow.
Stunning News.
One dude who worked for Trump for 10 days
no longer supports reelection, but the change
isn't really the surprise because nothing
has changed in terms of Trump.
Scaramucci isn't against the politics of Trump.
He's not really against the style of Trump
or the idiocy of Trump or anything else or
of the Republican Party.
This is just what happens when it's all about
your tribe.
Your buddy who scratches your back.
Scaramucci endlessly said in this interview,
the policies are great.
Republicans are great.
I'm a Republican, everything's great.
No they aren't.
You're just now mad at Trump.
You're feuding and getting attention and you're
no longer supporting reelection.
And by the way, him saying he's neutral, like
he's no longer a supporter of Trump's reelection,
but he's neutral on it.
Neutrality.
Are you serious?
Neutrality is being complicit in a case like
this.
And this is a real difference between the
left and the right.
Last week I told you about, uh, Republicans
in Texas trying to cover up a secret recording
of Republicans talking about a hit-list.
So let me just remind you what that was in
Texas, I believe it was a republican pack
guy, went to the Republican Texas State Speaker
of the House.
I'm going from memory, and they recorded a
conversation where they were talking about
a hit-list.
What Republicans do.
Republicans want to target in primaries in
Texas and the Texas Republican Party, a Texas
Republicans at large and National Republicans
decided after hearing the tape, wow, this
is really damaging.
We need to cover this up and make sure that
no one ever, that the tape never sees the
light of day on the left.
We would want that recording out immediately.
Okay?
If I found out that there was a recording
of Bernie or Warren or whoever saying horrible
things or have some left-wing group conspiring
to do whatever, I want to know who's toxic.
I want to know who's destructive.
I want the tape out.
We need to get these people out of our movement
and move on a as soon as possible.
For the right, it's just sport, and this is
another example.
Does Anthony Scaramucci actually believe that
Donald Trump's policies are good for the United
States?
Like he says, maybe, maybe he always has.
Maybe he never did, but it's what he's saying
and it's not even really what's at issue because
it's just sport.
It's checking boxes, it's winning friends.
Scaramucci lost a friend and now he's neutral
on Donald Trump.
Being, these are truly sick and amoral people,
but that's what makes them hard to fight.
We've got to find a way to do it, but it is
just sport.
It's checking boxes and even when they back
off of supporting a bad candidate or bad ideas,
it's rarely actually because of a change of
heart.
It's some kind of interpersonal conflict as
we're seeing here